ABOUT THAT AND HERE'S WHAT
HE SAID.
>> SO, THE QUESTION IS HAS
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY CHANGED
IRREVERSIBLY?
ARE WE GOING THROUGH A
MOMENT, YOU KNOW, A FRENZY
THAT WILL SUBSIDE AND THE
PARTY WILL GET BACK TO
MAKING ECONOMIC ARGUMENTS?
PUT SOME PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS, IF YOU WOULD.
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING
THROUGH A MOMENT AND I DO
THINK THE PARTY WILL GET
BACK TO THE PARTY OF MY
DAD'S KIND OF DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
MY DAD WAS A UNICON
DESTRUCTION WORKER.
AND HE USED TO SAY IF YOU
CARE ABOUT WORKERS, YOU VOTE
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
AND THAT'S THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT I GREW UP IN AND
I THINK WE'LL GET BACK
THERE.
THAT'S WHERE I GET THE SENSE
MOST DEMOCRATS ARE BUT THE
LOUDEST VOICES IN THE ROOM
ARE GETTING A LOT OF
COVERAGE RIGHT NOW AND THE
ACTIVISTS HAVE HAD A VERY
STRONG KIND OF VOICE IN THE
PARTY AND IN MANY WAYS THE
DNC HAS BEEN ENABLING IT,
THIS DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
>> Tucker: SO I -- THE LAST
POINT YOU ARE MAKING AND I'M
NOT A DEMOCRAT SO I'M FROM
THE OUTSIDE LOOKING IN.
BUT IT SEEMS TO BE RIGHT
JUST EVERYTHING I'M READING
AND HEARING.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
BECAUSE CLEARLY MOST MOST
VOTERS ARE CLOSER TO WHERE
YOU ARE THAN TO WHERE SOME
OF THESE OTHER CANDIDATES
ARE WHAT WOULD BE THE POINT?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU NEVER KNOW
WHO IS REALLY MAKING THE
DECISIONS BEHIND THE SCENES.
I MEAN, THEY ARE REQUIRING A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF SMALL
DOLLAR DONATIONS TO QUALIFY
FOR THE DEBATES.
YET, WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO TEND TO MAKE
SMALL DOLLAR DONATIONS
ONLINE TEND TO LIVE IN NEW
YORK AND CALIFORNIA AND TEND
TO REPRESENT THE MORE
EXTREME PARTS OF THE PARTY.
I MEAN, HALF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD THEIR
BASIC NECESSITIES.
I'M RUNNING TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT MAKING A LOT OF
DONATIONS TO DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES ONLINE.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
>> I THINK WE HAVE OUR
PRIORITIES ALL WRONG IN
TERMS OF YOU WHO WE ARE
CHOOSING WHO GETS TO DEBATE
ISSUES ON THE DEBATE STAGE
IN FRONT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SO, IN 1972,
DEMOCRATS REALLY HATED
RICHARD NIXON AND THEY
THOUGHT, YOU KNOW, ATTACKING
HIM PERSONALLY WOULD WORK.
AND THEY NOMINATED THE MOST
RADICAL PERSON THEY COULD
FIND.
AND THEY LOST.
AND THAT LESSON ENABLED BILL
CLINTON TO WIN TWO TERMS
BECAUSE HE LOOKED AT THAT
AND SAID THAT DOESN'T WORK.
WHY HAVE DEMOCRATS FORGOTTEN
THAT LEGISLATIVE?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVE MADE
THAT POINT.
I MEAN, IF YOU LOOK AT
MONDALE AND DUKAKIS THEY RAN
VERY FAR TO THE LEFT.
THEY TURNED OFF INDEPENDENT
VOTERS.
THEY DIDN'T RUN ENCORE
ECONOMIC ISSUES.
KITCHEN TABLE ISSUES.
POCKETBOOK ISSUES.
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE,
CREATING JOBS, IMPROVING
PEOPLE'S WAGES.
BUT BILL CLINTON AND
ACTUALLY BARACK OBAMA,
PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT BARACK
OBAMA.
HE WAS THE MORE MODERATE
CANDIDATE IN THE 2008
PRIMARY COMPARED TO JOHN
EDWARDS AND HILLARY CLINTON.
SO, THAT'S THE LESSON WE
HAVE GOT TO REMIND
OURSELVES.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY THERE IS A
LOT OF RAGE FOR THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT.
IF WE WANT TO BEAT HIM, WE
HAVE TO CAPTURE
INDEPENDENCE.
THE WAY TO CATCH
INDEPENDENTS IS BY RUNNING
ON THINGS THAT A MAJORITY OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SUPPORT.
IT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY SIMPLE.
WHAT MOST PEOPLE CARE ABOUT
IS, YOU KNOW, THEIR KID'S
EDUCATION, THEIR JOB, THEIR
HEALTHCARE, THEIR PAY,
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
KIDS.
THOSE BASIC ISSUES THAT
EFFECT EVERY AMERICAN.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO THAT
AS A PARTY.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I MEAN, WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING -- AND YOU COULD
SUBSTITUTE REPUBLICAN FOR
DEMOCRAT.
THAT'S THE SUBSTANCE --
THAT'S THE CORE OF POLITICS
RIGHT THERE.
THINK ABOUT.
>> AVERAGE AMERICAN CARE
ABOUT THEIR JOB AND PAY AND
CARE ABOUT THEIR KID'S
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND CARE
ABOUT THEIR HEALTHCARE AND
WANT TO KNOW THEIR NEXT
GENERATION THE KIDS AND
GRAND KIDS WILL HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THEY WANT
TO BE SAFE.
THAT'S WHAT MOST AMERICANS
CARE ABOUT.
>> Tucker: I KNOW.
IT'S NOT HARD.
IT'S SO WEIRD THAT YOU ARE
ONE OF THE ONLY GUYS SAYING